we're connecting with people on
doorsteps when people find out what you
can stand for and what we say they like
it and they then go out and vote for you
kid in bigger numbers equally we have
marked reckless who's obviously turns
out to be a very very impressive MP over
the years today popular on doorsteps
people like him on top of that as well
you Kip has really grown I mean you
can't compare where this party is now to
where it was even six months ago in
terms of the technology we have when it
comes to buy elections indeed if you
will about this technology when it come
it's Haywood Middleton we probably would
have on that maybe were the two thousand
majority as well so the party's on the
move the parties goer and its really
moved from being five years ago or
single issue pressure groupings of a
fully-fledged political party now we're
now able to know who our voters are
we've been able to focus in targets and
get our vault out there and a way that
we haven't had in the past which is
bliss been literally just be let's get a
good approach so we've tried and tested
those things in clacton and here both of
them such as well you know I think it's
an exciting time for us we're buoyant
we're confident we've got what the
Americans call the big mole at the
moment there may well be more defections
before the general election I can't
foresee any more bye elections because
by-elections cost money and I think it
would be a bit crazy to to have people
thought that bill and when we're talking
about four or five months before the
general election you know the party's
excising the pub excited the party's on
the move with all places